thanks Yasser after five days of
exciting chess we are finally ready to
Crown a champion we are a joint bar
Marine Mar usage who is the CEO of super
United Croatia as well as Michael
korarkovski the executive director of
the grand Chester and of course our
champion Magnus Carlson Michael I'm
going to give you the first word
yes thank you Chris it is excitement uh
here in Zagreb this is our last uh tour
in Europe third leg and we would like to
congratulate Magnus Carlson number one
player in the world who actually made
head trick here in Zagreb this year this
is the third win since 2019 in Zagreb
and once again Magnus Carlson showed
Excellency and Supremacy in these uh
tournament so would like again to
congratulate him and thanks our sponsors
super United Saint Louis chess club and
I would like to pass microphone to CEO
of super United Marine marus
thank you very much Michael
um I'm glad that I can welcome all the
all the players in Zagreb all the GCT
tour it's very nice to see you again
it's very nice that I will present the
second time in a row for me I haven't
had a chance to have a hat-trick but
hopefully I will have a hat-trick next
year so it's nice to present another
trophy to Mr Magnus congratulations I
know that you're a big fan of Croatia
I'm very happy for that thanks for uh
for all the nice pictures and photos and
thanks for promoting Croatia such a
beautiful country for a great holiday
and thanks for promoting chess and
helping to all the kids who are playing
chess because of you and all this good
chess players here with us thank you
very much
Magnus back-to-back victories in the
grand trust tour how are you feeling
right now
I'm completely spent I've had no energy
to to play today I felt you know uh
yesterday was such a great day and I
felt today that
I didn't have much to to give so I was
really just trying to get over the
finish line but I'm really happy that I
uh that I did uh and um
yeah feels always feels great to win
you've said it after the rapid portion
uh that your opponents will need to have
a great tournament in order to stop you
from winning the Bliss portion what gave
you that confidence
well I I thought that if I had like
a normal it's a good event it would be
would be tough and I think alireza
scored about this expected
um I think he made 13 points if I'm not
mistaken yeah which is really really
good plus eight uh but and also
yeah yarn and Fabi performed fairly
normally and I had my best best Blitz
result ever in the grand Chester and
that's obviously why it was not close
tell us about that the historical day
one might say you scored nine out of
nine if you count the uh two rapid games
11 out of 11 what did that mean for you
yeah it was
it was a was a fun day
um I can say that um it felt very very
special
um and uh
you know there are there are days when
um
yeah there are there are days there are
just better than the others I would say
that
um I love playing playing chess uh
and
uh
I mean there are tournaments that I can
still sort of win but
to be honest like that achievement feels
feels sweeter than than almost any
tournament tournament win because it's
it's something I've never done before
and
it's definitely a performance that left
the Chess World the speechless
congratulations uh Magnus you are the
champion of the 2023 super United rap
templates thank you so much for the last
time back to you guys in St Louis
thank you Christian once again our great
congratulations with Magnus and water
performance on day four one for the
history books absolutely it was a
privilege to watch truly and it's nice
to see uh Magnus struggling to find the
words as we commentators did as well as
the GCT tour finishes its European legs
and there we have our standings now